il appelle les capitons fédéric mur
assez sadni aujourd'hui une sarabande in
et les cieux les siens à un mur dunlop
n'a besoin de taille et ses côtés de
forces
il faut aller voir des gens elle
qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans déjà à signer
à le faire oui hélas le béton il faut
pas que nous en tête baissée dedans il
faut nous nous regarde bien avant de
commencer travail ça me conseille les
offres de service si le voir le plus
gros le tailler si le voir le plus gros
le tailler il faut couper avec le scat
est fausse
bon
c'est physique mais il faut rester
vigilant très très frappant de la
machine parce que j'aime c'est une
machine qui est très dangereux quel que
soit le modèle ont pratiqué comme ça et
comme ça vient comme ça il faut bouger
bouger dans la machine j'ai appelé le
bras
ça c'est beau coupé les grosses les
droits je branche mon sérieux grosses
branches comme ça
cette fois c'est fixé milliards il ya
pays lire on publie enfin suez a fait 2
millions parce que ça cesse et un gym
mur les rationnements 60 jours cette
fois vous arrosez parce que nous prend
la méditer le mur
envie voir des droits des trois places
mais nous n'avons plus de munitions à la
manière ça hypothèque lumière est jolie
ah oui tu un joli joli joli de manifs et
des salades ont le plaisir là des gens
on attend on a taillé et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est fait c'est joli
des gens de là on va espérer dans qu'on
va repousser pour retailler peut donner
une finition dernière fond